hallo herzlich willkommen
sallys welt heute gibt es ein ganz
besonderes video und zwar weil ich heute
türkischen tee zubereiten
wer uns kennt weiß dass immer auf
unserem herd wahrscheinlich 95 immer
diese teekanne steht und zwar dringend
wirklich gerne tee und das ist eine ganz
besondere art von schwarztee und zweite
türkische t bzw
die türkische zubereitung und dieses
video kommt jetzt also ich jetzt
wahrscheinlich nie gedacht dass ich mal
ein video drüber machen würde über den
türkischen tee
da die zubereitung wirklich sehr einfach
ist aber der zuschauerin von mir hat
sich die teekanne bei unserem shop
bestellt und habe dann gefragt jetzt
habe ich die teekanne zu hause was mache
ich damit
und da wurde mir erklärt dass
wahrscheinlich ganz viele überhaupt
nicht wissen wie man den tee zubereitet
und vor allem wahrscheinlich auch gar
nicht wissen welchen themen überhaupt
kauft denn viele kinder ist
wahrscheinlich aus dem urlaub genau aus
dem urlaub das bringt mir diesen und der
türkische texanische türkischen kultur
natürlich verankert verankert und wenn
wir besuch bekommt oder oder irgendwie
zu gästen geht bekommen hat immer tabu
zu jeder tageszeit morgens mittags
abends die nordhessen nach dem essen
es gibt immer den türkischen haushalten
zu 80 läuft immer die teekanne genau auf
dem herd und deswegen gibt es heute ein
kleines video und wir können denn
natürlich von zu hause aus aber viele
wahrscheinlich eben aus dem urlaub da
gibt es aber ganz viele unterschiede
also falls er sagt ja ich hab den themen
der türkei schon getrunken
der hat mir aber nicht so gut geschmeckt
dann solltet ihr diesen tier trotzdem
mal probieren denn der tele türkei und
betty den wir hier zu bereiten
das sind zwei ganz verschiedene schuhe
den tt hier ist viel leckerer also ganz
kurz zum tee tee wird aus der teepflanze
gewonnen und es sind einfach diese
getrockneten blätter und ob jetzt
schwarztee weißer tee oder grüner tee
ausgangspunkt ist immer die teepflanze
und die herstellung bewegt dann eben die
verschiedenen typen also das heißt
grüner tee und schwarztee bestehen alle
aus der gleichen grundzutat sage ich
jetzt mal und beim schwarzen tee ist es
so dass da diese zellwände aufgebrochen
werden und die oxidieren also die
reagieren mit dem sauerstoff in der luft
und dann werden die eben schwarz daher
das spannendste und der schwarztee ist
von allem der aromatische und auch der
witzigste und da gibt es aber natürlich
auch ganz viele unterschiede wir zum
beispiel treten gerne denn john t der
kommt aus sri lanka und das ist auch der
täter
sehr würzig schmeckt aromatisch schmeckt
da gibt es aber natürlich dann auch eben
unterschiede
wir verwenden immer diesen tee hier und
zwar sind es einzelne teeblätter die
sieht man auch diesen sehr groß und man
erkennt auch tatsächlich diese einzelnen
blätter und wenn die später dann mit
wasser überbrüht werden sieht man auch
richtig dass es wirkliche blätter sind
dann gibt es noch den anderen täters ist
der hier
da sieht er pulverförmige aus und das
ist der diese zeit also eine typische
form also auch so angaben waren
anbaugebiet aus der schwarzmeerküste
außer diese pulver t wir haben auch
wirklich gäste die kommen dann und sagen
habt ihr den wahren täter den mann
schäfer thema ansprechen pulver jetzt
marazzi sagen
der physiker ist aber sehr aromatisch
eigentlich viel in zu bitter naja ich
viel zu bieten
deswegen mag ich nicht so und vor allem
wer pulver für mich ist landet der markt
der satz immer mt und dann habe ich in
die hand nahm und deswegen oder was ihm
fehlt haben dynamischen vollführt und
ich kenne das von zu hause aus diesen
blättert er sage ich jetzt mal haben wir
immer zu hause getrunken und den
entscheid diesen pulver c hat mein papa
immer bei der arbeit getrunken
das weiß ich noch unterricht eben ganz
anders vielen schmeckt er besser uns
persönlich schmeckt er blättert besser
was gar nicht geht sind beutelt es das
ist wirklich eine beleidigung für jeden
teetrinker weil einfach beutelt erstens
mal nicht richtig im wasser schwimmen
können das heißt das aroma kann sich gar
nicht richtig verbreiten und vor allen
dingen ist es viel zu teuer bezahlt
nehme ich dann wirklich person päckchen
tee zwei euro und hat am ende 43 gramm
tee mit 1 4 wollen und 1,7 gramm und
wirklich also der bonität der kunden hat
der war wirklich ein ganz ganz schlauer
denn endlich eine goldene nase verdient
weil im gegensatz kannst du oder zeigen
kilo der kunst ungefähr die halbe kilo
kostet fünf euro
die idee ist den anderen namen fürs
langsam kurs auf fünf euro genau das
sieht man dann zum beispiel auch ja
praktisch also blätterte und deswegen
stelle ich jetzt mal den und den weg
nicht durcheinander kommt also ist alles
geschmackssache
es ist kein schlechterer gut es ist
geschmackssache macht alles nur keine
teebeutel
das ist eine beleidigung für jeden jeden
türken für jeden teetrinker der türke
sagt sauber macho sein heißt der
geschüttelte t der beutel take it easy
und das geht dank der schwarz es
übrigens bei richtiger lagerung 18
monate haltbar das heißt man sie kühl
trocken und luftdicht verpacken
ich packte noch einmal um und macht ihn
so eine luftdichte dose und dann hält er
auch wirklich eine zeit lang wobei bei
uns nicht ganz 18 monate hält weil wir
einfach zu viel tee trinken also bei uns
reicht vielleicht will ich muss man
ehrlich sagen der 15 tage maximum im
monat würde ich schon sagen
aber die kleine packung ein halber monat
und ich muss dazu sagen dass wir früher
eigentlich nur teetrinker waren aber
mittlerweile trinken auch gerne kaffee
kaffeemaschinen vollautomaten
umständlich ja was wollte ich noch sagen
beim schwarz ist es ganz wichtig dass
man den vor allem wenn man zum beispiel
eisenmangel hat sagt man ja auch dass
man den jetzt nicht so eisenhaltigen
lebensmitteln dazu trinken sollte denn
der schwarze verhindert die
eisenaufnahme im körper
das heißt man kann ihn trotzdem trinken
auch wenn man eisenmangel hat aber dann
eben nicht zu den lebensmitteln dazu
genau deswegen wie gesagt wenn die
eisenmangel habt dann immer vorsichtig
beim teetrinken
ich will schon freundin die eisenmangel
haben und nicht mehr so viel trinken wie
damals er früher
ich habe zum beispiel auch in der
schwangerschaft dann immer maximal also
wirklich maximal eine kleine tasse am
tag getrunken und dann auch nicht jeden
tag weil ich dann einfach gedacht habe
nie gekommen da muss man auch mit dem
eisen mit dem eisen
mangel und so weiter machen deswegen
amstel reduziert also mir im kino
erzählt ja genau da ist koffein mit drin
deswegen sollten kinder schwappte
möglichst nichts trinken
ich hoffe ich so sagen muss als kind
durften wir immer mit trinken ihr alle
kinder haben früher also ich habe ich
alle mit der muttermilch zusammen in
schwarz zentrum wirklich erklärt heute
so einiges an vorbereitung und zwar habe
ich jetzt hier diese teekanne die kennt
sie aus unserem shop
und zwar ist das besondere daran mache
zwei teile einmal den unteren teil da
habe ich jetzt schon kaltes wasser
eingefüllt es wird gleich aufgekocht und
den oberen teil und zwar deswegen bei
dem schwarzsee ist es jetzt nicht so wie
zum beispiel bei früchtetee dass man
einfach einmal was ausfüllt und dann der
tee fertig ist man kann hier selbst
bestimmen wie stark oder wie schwach man
den tee trinken möchte das heißt hier
oben wird ein konzentrat zubereitet und
unten ist dann das wasser womit man den
tee mischen und später der murat zum
beispiel den helleren und nicht im
dunkeln auf türkisch touch also hält er
über kim little genau und jetzt machen
wir das einfach mal und zwar kann ich
jetzt hier schon mal das wasser zum
kochen bringen
also tut dann mit den 2 teil tut dir da
will ich stelle mich ein bisschen heller
ja die chemisch also männer trinken dass
er müssen dunkler und frauen müssen sich
einfach bei uns ist aber anders strom
heller ich das aber nicht ganz dunkel
jetzt nehme ich den c und zwar wird also
man kann jetzt keine ganz genauen
angaben machen ich werde jetzt vier
esslöffel drei bis vier esslöffel tee
nehmen und es reicht dann bei uns jetzt
wir sind jetzt hier vier personen reicht
es dann so dass jeder ungefähr zwei
große tassen tee trinken kann man kann
aber auch gar keine genauen angaben
machen wie viele täter daraus entsteht
denn je nachdem ob man ihn stärker oder
schwächer trinkt kann man eben mehr oder
wenig auch lieber nicht zu viel ich
würde nicht so viel
das heißt ich mache drei esslöffel und
jetzt nehme ich den tee und werden wir
erst mal kalt abwaschen und nochmal
abgießen befördern das heiße wasser rein
kommt
jetzt kocht das wasser und ich stelle
den herd aus und das ist ganz kurz
abkühlen damit jetzt nicht 100 grad
heiss direkt auf den tee kommt sondern
auch etwa 95 grad abkühlt und die form
ist so also die teekanne unten ist sie
im agiert und passt auch auf den
induktionsherd auf dem gasherd oder auf
den normalen auf eine normale ceran
kochplatte und oben habe ich diese
porzellan keramik teekanne bringt so ein
deckel mit dabei die muss man hier so
andré und umdrehen wenn man nämlich
später dann den tee ausgibt dann fällt
der deckel nicht ab unsere ersten tag an
nicht so und deswegen war monatelang der
deckel der teekanne kaputt bei unseren
zuschauern aufgefallen
jetzt kann ich hier das wasser eigen
gießen und zwar nimmt jetzt so viel bis
die blätter komplett bedeckt sind und
bis sie dann im wasser schwimmen
jetzt kommt der deckel wieder drauf wird
verschlossen und hier unten fühle ich
jetzt gleich noch mal frisches wasser
ein
und das ist bei der teezubereitung
übrigens ganz wichtig dass man nicht
immer wieder das gleiche wasser
aufgekocht auch jetzt wenn jetzt wenn
das wasser mal abgekühlt ist dann
schüttete es am besten weg in die blumen
zum beispiel und nehmt dann wieder
frisches wasser denn je länger das
wasser kocht umso weniger sauerstoff ist
drin und es schmeckt man dann auch
wirklich genau tier also die teekanne
märkten heiße montagmorgen gemacht aber
es liegt wirklich extrem sauerstoff im
wasser ein bisschen hab da überhaupt ein
ganz anderes geschmacksempfinden das
heißt das wasser frisch und trotzdem
mögen besuch kommt macht man das machen
wir in frischen thema so gerne tut
normalerweise immer frischen wir kochen
teilweisen zweimal paketierung ja wobei
man das echt nicht toll weil es schmeckt
halt schon anders jetzt hoffe ich dass
wasser auf und stellt dann den herd
runter auf etwas stufe 2 bis 3
das ist noch ganz leicht köcheln denn
der tee wird heiß getrunken und zwar
beim schwarz tisches über 80 wenn wir
zwischen grünen tee nimmt den rund 80
grad trägt also wie schwarztee bereits
heiß werden lassen und wie kaká mit
einem begrünten nicht über über gibt es
auch das war nicht über 75 genau und ich
werde jetzt den tee hier stehen lassen
etwa 10 bis 15 minuten dann schmeckt er
uns am besten und man muss dann wenn t
später auch nicht abgeben das heißt nach
diesen 15 minuten bleibt der tee satz
trotzdem mit drin
natürlich wird mit der zeit immer
stärker aber er wird jetzt nicht bitter
dadurch dass ich neben auch vorher
abgewaschen habe und eben schonend
zubereitet haben und wir warten jetzt
einfach ganz geschichtliches rossmanns
osmanischen reiches jahre gegeben hat
die haben früher eigentlich muss kaffee
getrunken und dann aufgrund der kriege
wurde dann diese café gute diese
seitenstraße wie sich nennt oder
abgetrennt dann haben sie keinen kaffee
mehr bekommen die türken oder die
osmanen da fühlt sich von den türken
loßmann
und dann haben die essen die
ausgeflippten gesagt wir brauchen
irgendwas ersatz und somit hamm
gegründet haben die das befohlen dass
tee angebaut wird er angebaut als ersatz
für den kaffee und somit kam dass auch
über die teehäuser über wien die ganzen
teehäusern wie das kam wirklich über das
osmanische reich also eigentlich haben
die türken 1888 es erst mal probiert
anzubauen in bursa und das haben sie nur
einmal geschafft weil die tt war die
pflanze die hat keine früchte die haben
das nicht hingekriegt haben es nur
einmal hingekriegt und dann als sie dann
georgien erobert haben haben die russen
in georgien eigentlich schon tee
angebaut
dann haben sie gemerkt dass die georgien
ungefähr sogleich ist wie die
schwarzmeerregion der türkei und dann
haben sie einfach den russen auch
beigebracht bekommen kann man sagen wie
man bauen haben sie in der
schwarzmeerregion gerade um riese den
schwarzsee angebaut stadt gar nicht
natürlich will ich denke lanka die
russen zahle schon irgendwie holst die
türken haben sie mitgenommen und europa
ich finde das geschäft einer
geschichtsstunde halten
ich habe immer die hast du schon viele
geschichten bei der letzten geschichte
wurde hier erzählt hast mich geheiratet
solange sich gezogen
jetzt zeige ich euch wie man installiert
also habt ihr schonmal täglicher
gerichtet und zwar sind verschiedene die
hier vorne sind eher so die touristen
gläser sage ich jetzt mal weil sie
einfach sehr orientalisch aussehen
touris meistens aus der türkei mit er
und denken die haben jetzt sollte man
sie findet
findest du diese teglas form eigentlich
gar nicht in der tür also in richtig
türkischen haushalten genau das ist er
so muss ich sagen
seine englische form oder möchte sehr
ausdünnen und soweit meine mama hat mich
aus porzellan gläser japanischer und das
hier ist die normale türkische form das
ist so eine tulpenform also in der mitte
etwas schlapp und dann wieder nach unten
dicker und das hier ist eine große tasse
ist schon eher was für den murat weil
der sein te ungefähr 85 grad heiss
trinkt und den tanz sofort lehrer und
damit ich dann etwas schenken muss oder
ersthelfer nimmt die große tafel oder
vorne an
aber man nimmt dann am besten beide
teekannen in die hand und gehst dann vom
dunklen und dann kommt das wasser
hinterher und dann kann man eben
bestimmen wie dunkel oder wie hält man
ihn haben möchte jetzt hier ein thema
wird durchgerutscht aber normalerweise
rutscht fast nix durch denn in der
teekanne ist so sind so löcher drin also
die sonne sieht genau gesagt filter und
dann rutscht eigentlich nichts mit durch
das ist jetzt für mich und was trinkst
du nicht so stark und jetzt kann hier
stellt man sich stärken punkte ein
das märkische zu schwach was man nicht
machen türkischen ist denn tee mit milch
trinken
die schau die beleidigung also geborgen
und dann noch milch verlangen das ist
dann fliegst du raus wirklich da müsste
weg jetzt kann man wenn man möchte denn
mit zucker trinken das macht der murat
ich glaube vor dem start am 2 genau das
mal wieder vielleicht auf einem auge 1
herunter ich trinke tee mittlerweile
komplett ohne zucker ich mag den so
meine tante mag ihn zum beispiel gerne
mit ein bisschen zitrone gibt's ja also
ich sage ich wie die engeln damit
beliebig das ist eine gemeinde velen ist
beleidigung und ihr dürft auch die
türken nicht nachzufragen damit auch
sauer
die richtung so gut aber ich kann so
viel zu heiß ich hoffe ich konnte euch
jetzt mit diesem video die fragen
beantworten zur teezubereitung zur
geschichte und und auch nicht die schuhe
schlüpfen
das ist auch an es geht ja nicht
gegangen hat schläft auf den tisch
nämlich gar nicht möglich
deine eltern schlüpfen ich hoffe dass
euch dieses video gefallen hat falls ihr
doch noch fragen habt zum tee und
schreibt sie gerne in die kommentare und
wir beantworten wir euch gerne also ich
wünsche euch viel spaß beim nachmachen
und wir sehen uns das nächste mal bis
dann tschüss patrick doppel ohne
schlüpfen
ich kann nur heißen wir was vergessen
wir wollten nämlich teekannen verlosen
und zwar verlosen wir zwei dekaden mit
500 gramm tee jeweils an unsere
zuschauer
und was müssen sie dafür tun einfach an
kommentarspalten ich hätte gerne ttk
liegt in deiner verantwortung
wer cool an kurzen kürzen witz nicht ich
will die leute wenigstens die kommentare
lesen sie lachen auch immer wegen der
ach so
okay was tolles machen vielleicht passt
auf ihn aufgepasst und zwar wie heißt es
hauptanbaugebiet der türkei
wenn er müsste zurückspulen genau dann
schreibt es in die kommentare und dann
verlosen wir zwei theken mit jeweils
einem pc mit 500 gramm also viel glück
und biete nur mitmachen wenn ihr
wirklich noch nie türkischen tee
getrunken also welche mittäter gehabt
oder sowas dann lasst anderen die
vorlauf aber mit nicht doch könnte dem
anderen pkw
dkk nicht okay alles